they are trying to smear the good name
of Oliver Anthony this guy who wrote the
biggest song in the world rich men north
of Richmond and we got we got a couple
of tweets there's more than just these
going around because he gave a statement
to Griff I believe it's Griff Jenkins
are on Fox News
let me play the clip for you first that
people are sharing here you go I mean we
are the Melting Pot of the world and
that that's what makes us strong is our
diversity and we need to learn to
harness that and appreciate it and not
use it as a political tool to keep
everyone separate from each other you
know I mean so that's the clip they're
showing and this guy uh nine millimeter
SMG says accent disappeared say the line
diversity makes a strong clap still of
it to find a single person to explain to
me how diversity is a strength explain
to me how a cohesive unit is less
functional anyone looks like he got the
call from the rich men north of Richmond
we then have this one where they said
Oliver Anthony quote We Are The Melting
Pot of the world and that's what makes
us strong our diversity such a letdown
did he sell out already to the rich men
north of Richmond oh they are trying to
smear this regular guy a working-class
guy calling out the fat cats in the
elites with a with an out of context
quote I'm going to show you the full
quote
he said I don't see our country lasting
more than another generation the way we
are headed we have to go back to the
roots of what made this country great in
the first place which was our sense of
community We Are The Melting Pot of the
world and that's what makes us strong is
our diversity we need to learn to
harness that and appreciate it and not
use it as a political tool to keep
everyone separate from each other first
of all if you thought this guy who wrote
this song was going to come out and just
agree with literally everything you said
then you were mistaken more importantly
the dude is saying exactly what we say
all the time one Community is the most
important thing that's why we're doing
this coffee shop that's why we want to
do Saturday morning cartoons we call it
where we bring families together he says
we have to go back to the roots of what
made this country great in the first
place
absolutely we talk about this all the
time
everybody who championed his song
there's no reason for anyone to pretend
that they're outraged over him saying
this we completely agree this is the
antithesis of wokeness woke people are
like the country is inherently evil
since 1619 the slave ocracy has ruled
Supreme and white supremacy must be
destroyed and here's a guy saying no no
we got to go back we got to go back to
what made this country great the idea of
diversity I'll explain it for you
diversity does not mean that you take a
whole bunch of people of different
backgrounds isolate them from each other
and then tell each of them that they're
all their enemy diversity is what the
Melting Pot truly was when you came to
this country you melted into it meaning
you became part of the greater culture
Oliver Anthony is correct I like this
guy me too man diversity for instance
very literally would be like if you have
a bunch of small a bunch of short people
and then they can't get the fruit out of
the tree they die off uh now you have a
group that's a bunch of tall people that
can't get into the hole in the ground to
catch the rabbits so they starve they
all die off now you have some tall
people and some short people the short
people going to the holes the tall
people get the fruit I love this story
diversity is strength completely wrong
but right in so many ways you need to
catch rabbits in the holes
and tall people can still catch rabbits
but your point is 100 skin color like
are not not necessarily the color but
our ancient genetics can make us more or
less resistant to uh sickness like
certain bacteria and viruses so like if
a virus comes through and wipes out a
lot of one ethnicity or one you know
cultural background the others are
spared the species survive listen it's
called hybrid Vigor they there was this
study that I read a while ago it shows
that people who have kids with people
from the further away your partner is
from as a point of origin from the
planet the the better their their
child's immune system may turn out to be
and I'm like that's really really
fascinating that is the American Melting
Pot idea of diversity that two things
come together and become one but more
importantly
what is it saying with communities
Melting Pot that means when a an
immigrant family comes to the United
States they don't create their isolated
little pocket Community where they don't
speak English they integrate they melt
into what America already is and are
underneath our cultural umbrella and
then you get like Chinatown and New York
which is you know Chinese
and it adheres to our rules and our laws
and our constitution they end up for the
most part learning English I mean that's
that's why they move to America is to
learn English and become part of the
culture so he's like there's the people
that that are criticizing him it seems
like and this is this is an assumption
but it seems like they're people that
are
expressing that they feel like he's not
right enough like not right wing enough
like he is a plant leftist because he's
saying the quote unquote leftist
buzzwords things like diversity but I
think the guy's just not an extremely
online dude right like we all see you
know the term diversity and there's all
kinds of things attached to it comes
with a ton of baggage because of the way
that the left uses it because of what
the the term diversity means according
to uh Scholars and and the way that it
the the the discrepancy uh in the
definition versus the way that the left
tends to apply it so there's all that
stuff attached to it right but if you're
just a normal guy that goes to work and
you know writes a song the idea of we
should have a diverse country is
something that you especially like his
age that's something that everybody kind
of grew up with the idea that everybody
comes to America and or the people that
come to America everyone can be American
you come here and it's the Melting Pot
blah blah
that's something that is that has been a
an integral part of the United States's
story you know for the vast majority of
of our history and so I think that he
wasn't I think that it was just the
situation of he is kind of a normie and
people are applying a lot of uh
extremely online context to a guy that
doesn't is totally unfortunately I love
it you know why he's a normie yeah he
said very Normy things Fat Cats in
Washington they're bad fat people on
welfare are exploiting our taxes and the
left attacked him and the right cheered
for him that says a whole lot about what
these factions are the Democrats are the
party of the wealthy Elites and they
were offended by what he said yeah and
the right is a disparate group of people
of varying ideologies for the most part
that are anti-establishment anti-woke
and and generally agree to disagree I
mean when we do this show the left calls
it right wing despite the fact we have
people of all different political
backgrounds having conversations so this
guy represents just a regular dude he
lives in a trailer he's out down south
in Virginia I I love his videos he's got
one where he's in front of a river and
he's just playing the song ain't got a
dollar and I'm like and the Train's
going by he's gotta wait for the train
that's super cool just a regular dude
who wrote this song that had some good
lyrics I Wish politicians would look out
for minors and not just a minor on an
island somewhere I mean like yeah he
kind of just hit the nail on the head
with the hammer with a lot of the stuff
and uh you know I like folk so for me
it's easy yeah but uh I think a lot of
people when you watch him perform and
you see the people in the audience like
nodding along to it he's speaking to
just regular people right that's the
thing I don't understand is we're
getting mad at him when he's like
they're like oh most people are pretty
you know middle middle of the road most
people think like pretty pretty Center
the way ideas and everyone's mad at him
from well not everyone but some people
are mad at him on the right like we've
just seen here and people on the left
from Adam it's like this is what most
people think like you guys should all be
championing him because this is what
most people think he's the American and
I'm not so sure that he is uh it's funny
they call him Anthony even though his
name is Chris was a Lunsford or
something yeah yeah is it Lunsford Chris
Anthony Chris Anthony Lunsford is his
name they call him Anthony because
Oliver Anthony's his base his stage
performance name or whatever his
grandfather but uh I gotta tell you I
don't think he's super politically
active he says the middle middle the
road kind of guy but he's also the kind
of guy that was activated by Donald
Trump a regular guy who's just like you
know what man let the molotov cocktail
ball in China shop go
in 2016 when I went to all of Trump's
campaign rallies were exactly like this
guy yeah they told me that they were not
Republicans they hated Republicans they
were not conservative but they hated the
politicians they hated the political
establishment and they just wanted Trump
to do something do Trump give people
fire to like break up the Deep State he
was so excited about draining the swamp
and it didn't have he put John Bolton in
and he got all these weirdos involved
and didn't do it because he didn't know
how or believed the Liars like he
believed
I just I but he did light a fire under
people's ass like he woke people up that
there was an administrative State I
think most of the United States people
didn't even realize that we were being
run by bureaucrats at the time so I will
give him that and maybe yeah if he if he
woke Oliver up that's a huge deal
whenever no I don't think he woke up
Oliver individually I'm saying it's
people like him that are considered the
Forgotten demographic when it comes to
voting whenever Trump says you know
they're not coming after me they're
coming after you know the people who
support me the people who sort of are
behind me I think this whole story is
sort of an example of that you know you
just detailed how his how his rise
really is an entire Fu not just to like
the music industry but just to The
Establishment as a whole what he sings
about who he is just as a person so it's
like they have to character assassinate
him I don't know if you guys saw but
they had pulled up some old like YouTube
videos that he had liked trying to
allegiate with some crazy conspiracy
there so I think this just goes to show
how it's like you know Must Destroy
Oliver Anthony because he represents
sense everything that we oppose and I
think it goes back to what we were
talking about earlier you know they love
to artificially create all these
divisions whether it's the race the
gender the sex you know I'm sure I don't
have to enumerate all those for the
people who watch this show but I think
the biggest lie in terms of division
that we've been sold really is
Republican Democrat because I think that
orientation of the world is just is so
wrong because it's people like Oliver
Anthony and its people it's basically
the people who listen to Oliver
Anthony's music and feel like they have
a voice and what he's singing about and
the people who listen to his music and
are like oh my God he's singing about me
and I think that's sort of the line that
represents like the two factions in this
country maybe faction is a harsh word
but um they have to destroy him because
he represents everything well I think
the factions
many people describe them in many
different ways the two parent factions
but it's really just are you in the cult
are you not yeah 100 that's that's just
all it is because like
you know there was this viral video
going around where a dude's wearing uh
Biden for a resident shirt or something
like that and he's talking to two
liberals who don't realize he hates he
doesn't like Joe Biden and he's asking
them questions and then whenever he just
says something about Biden that is bad
they're like that's not sure where'd you
hear that and he's like he's like in the
news and then it was funny he was like
well Biden's taking bribes and engaging
corrupt business and they're like
where's your evidence for that and then
he lists off all of these things that
have come out the IRS whistleblowers the
barisma video and like he just keeps
going and then they're like I don't
believe any of that it's just like okay
you're in a couple belief it's it's
believe it's the word it's right there
they give it to you
um
the uh we were uh when you were saying
we were talking about diversity that
term that he used diversity and I we
talked about this before the show a
little bit that what's happening is I
don't want to say the Communists because
it might not just be Communists that are
doing this but people are twisting
definitions in the Modern Age definition
the word feminism definition of the word
diversity definition of uh Equity yeah
that's all the time that's all communism
yeah the definition of the word pandemic
like what the Spanish Flu was a pandemic
I didn't see that happen to people this
time during but uh
so if if you buy into the the Twisted
definition of the word diversity you're
going to fall into this like thinking
he's a bad guy because you believe the
enemies uh Twisted definition of your
own material like don't buy the
don't don't fall into the game of the of
the twisting of language right now right
don't believe the Communists yeah is it
just Communists I probably is
share the Communist right now the the
left more broadly but they share our uh
our lexicon but they don't share our
dictionary no exactly they've used the
same words that we use but the meanings
that they apply to them uh are different
and some of them when you're dealing
with the the more consequentialist type
uh they will use both meanings so for
instance they'll use the term rate like
they'll say racism like if you talk
about racism they'll say well that's not
racism because racism is is Prejudice
plus power right but then later on in
the comment they'll use the term racism
and they'll mean bigotry yeah so they'll
use both definitions which puts the
person they're talking with at a
disadvantage because they're literally
confusing them intentionally because
they're not looking to resolve the uh
the conversation or they're not looking
to to converse with someone they're not
looking to collaborate they're looking
to prove the other person wrong don't
get a you know get the Clipper pressure
yeah but they're not looking to
collaborate on an idea that produces
something that is actually productive
they're looking to compromise right
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time